What I would say is are other young man.
I want to open your eyes
and look at the world.
Okay,
right now please see what is the most
needed thing in the world right now.
You don't do some fanciful
thing that you like to do.
You must do what's most needed isn't it
isn't the top.
If you get carried away by a situations,
people become like this. It's useful,
but it is not the basic thing.
Today you saw a train burning,
so you wanted to become a firefighter.
Tomato.
You saw something.
You wanted to become that in
reaction and emotional reaction.
You choose to become something.
It could be useful on some level,
but now when most young people
cannot think you're thinking,
what should I do with my life
and set the thought has come.
I would say spend little more time on it
not being influenced by anybody
or anything. Simply look at it.
What is it that the humanity needs most?
What is it that the world needs most
today? I want you to recognize that
the only thing that needs to be
fixed on this planet as human beings,
everything else is fine, isn't it? So,
so I would say all young people,
not just you,
let's take a break from what you're doing.
Just caught up because you did.
You did school,
you went to a college
because he didn't call it.
You went to the next thing and the
next thing and you end up with a phd.
What to do. It's a dangerous, you know,
because the education
scientists are saying if you
go through 20 years of formal
education and landed
with a phd or something,
70% of your intelligence
is irrevocably destroyed.
Yes, you become a very
knowledgeable, he did.
And to your knowledge has no use because
whatever beheaded the hold of nos,
a high school kid can open the
Internet and talk the same language.
Uganda one looks smarter anymore
with what you've collected isn't the
cause of just about anybody.
We'll pop these things because
it's all over the place.
So are you preparing for a
university or the universe?
That's where you have to live unless
you wanted to become an academic.
I'm not saying these things are wrong,
but human beings,
sensible human beings must inverse
their life towards what is needed most,
isn't it not some fancy one thing
that I want to do or you want to do?
You can do whatever joyfully
are miserably, isn't it?
And just because today you think by
doing this I will be happy if your goal
don't ever think you will stay happy
by doing the that after some time
everybody,
when they got their first job,
what a beautiful day it was.
You went to this,
Mandy living office,
sat there and wow,
how are we 12 but after a few years,
sitting behind the same table,
it's taking your life,
the same job, the same
marriage, the same situations.
They're taking your life and one day they,
it looked like heaven.
After some time it looks
like hell isn't it?
Not because there's something wrong with
those jobs simply because you're doing
it for the wrong reason. You're
just doing it for the wrong reasons.
That's all.
Okay.
Now that you're thinking.
I would say take a few weeks off.
We have a link to give you the space.
Just a uninfluenced by anybody.
Just look at it
did have many things you will want
to do right now because of immediate
compulsions.
You're broke right now.
You think the first thing is to find a
job or some of the comparison with the
new thing? Do the first thing is
to do this beside your compulsions.
Suppose you had none of these compulsions.
What would you like to do with life?
That's what you should do.
You should not decide your life and the
course of your life based on immediate
compulsions you decide in your life.
If you do this for a hundred years
and look back after a hundred years,
if you look back,
is it still worthwhile you do that?
There are many others
who would like to be you?
Oh, I wish I was 20 and I wish I
could think what to do at that time.
I did something that any number of
people here now that you're 20 and you're
fortunate that you're thinking and it's
fortunate that you're here. It's time,
you'd think straight
before you do anything.
Okay.